hello and welcome to met simplified the
immune system is the basic defense
system of the body that protects us from
harmful pathogens and diseases the
immune system consists of various types
of cells and different proteins that
kill the harmful invading microorganisms
and protects our body from disease in
this video we will discuss about the
human immune system what is a basic
structure of the human immune system and
how it functions then we will also look
at some of the factors which affect your
immune system and the differences
between the innate and acquired immunity
you can get the lecture handouts from
this video and all our other previous
videos by clicking the join button below
you can also join our community at
patreon.com this will also unlock some
of the cool features like behind the
scenes of these videos exclusive content
early notifications and much more so
let's begin with the immune system the
overall function of the immune system is
to prevent or limit infection when the
immune system first recognizes invasion
by pathogens it responds to address the
problem if an immune response cannot be
activated when there is sufficient need
problems arise like infections and other
diseases on the other hand when an
immune response is activated without a
real threat or is not turned off once
the danger passes different problems
arise such as allergic reactions and
autoimmune diseases let's look at the
basic structure of the immune system the
immune system essentially consists of
three layers of defense that protects
our body from various types of attacks
from microorganisms and even nonliving
things like toxins metals etc each layer
consists of different mechanisms of
immunity and when one layer is breached
or invaded the mechanisms of the layer
below it come into action until the
attack is successfully controlled the
first and basic layer of human immune
system is the barrier immunity below
which is the innate immunity and finally
we have the adaptive immunity or the
acquired immunity let's decode these
terms one by one and understand about
the basic structure of the human immune
system so the first layer
defense in human immune system is the
barrier immunity and the most important
part of para immunity is of course the
skin
skin is considered as the largest organ
of human body with an average surface
area of one point seven three meter
square in simple terms physical barriers
prevent pathogens such as bacteria and
viruses from entering the organism the
skin not only provides a physical
barrier that prevents any pathogens from
entering your body but it also provides
protection by means of chemical and
biological barriers skin cells produce
and secrete important antimicrobial
proteins that kill the invading
microorganisms the skin also contains
immune cells that help to stop the
microbes from invading our body
shedding of skin epithelium also known
as desquamation helps to remove bacteria
and other infectious agents that may
have adhered to the skin surface similar
types of barrier immunity is also
provided by many other surfaces present
inside our body including the surface
lining of our respiratory system the
gastrointestinal system the genital
urinary system and the surface lining of
our nose and pharynx all these types of
surfaces provide a physical barrier that
prevents the attack from pathogens and
they also provide various types of
chemical anti microbials which try to
stop the invading pathogens at a very
early stage for example the surface
lining of our respiratory system has
these small hairlike projections that
are known as respiratory cilia a special
property of the Celia is that they have
a particular direction of movement by
virtue of which they remove any foreign
material that may have entered our lungs
while breathing this provides a strong
physical barrier that prevents buildup
of microorganisms and other foreign
material in our lungs defects in the
function of Celia are very common in
smokers which leads to higher incidence
of chest infections the respiratory
surface also provides various types of
antimicrobial chemicals like surfactants
mucus and defensins which help to stop
the invading microorganisms our stomach
releases strong acids with a very low pH
that kills most of the microorganisms
that we accidentally ingest while eating
the tears in our eyes also contains
special antimicrobial proteins like
lysozyme that kill many pathogens the
constant flushing of Tears also prevents
any buildup of foreign material in our
eyes which is also an example of barrier
immunity
so this was the first line of defense of
our immune system and this was known as
the barrier immunity now what happens
when a microorganisms say a bacteria or
a virus evades our barrier immunity and
is successful in entering our body in
that case the microorganism is met by
our next layer of immune system that is
known as the innate immunity now to
understand about the innate immunity you
have to first understand about the
meaning of the word innate the word
innate is made up of two words in and
Nate in means inside and Nate means born
so innate is something that you are born
with now why this is known as innate
immunity this is because the innate
immunity is present in our body from the
time we were born meaning it is already
present when we take birth this is in
comparison to a third layer of immunity
that is adaptive immunity that develops
after we were born the innate immune
system is an older evolutionary defense
strategy as compared to the adaptive
immunity that developed later the innate
immunity is nonspecific meaning it does
not have special mechanism of action for
different types of pathogens we will
discuss the differences between the
innate and the adaptive immunity later
in this video
now per se the barrier immunity is also
a part of the innate immunity since it
is also presents in Spurs but for
understanding this topic it is better to
divide these types of immunity into
three categories now let's talk about
the innate immune system in detail the
defense system of the innate immunity
consists of the various types of cells
and the complement system let's first
talk about the various types of cells of
the innate immune system and look at
their basic functions the different
types of cells in our innate immune
system are neutrophils mast cells
basophils dendritic cells
eosinophils monocytes macrophages and NK
cells or the natural killer cells all
these cells are type of white blood
cells or WBC's also known as leukocytes
leuco meaning white and sites meaning
cell
the neutrophils are the most abundant
immune cells making up about 60 to 70
percent of the total population of
immune cells they form an essential part
of the innate immune system one word you
will hear a lot in this immune system is
the word fake-o cytosis Fei Jie means
eating and cytosis means by a cell so
Faygo cytosis in simple terms is cell
eating neutrophils are a type of
phagocytes that detect and eat the
pathogen within the cell within the cell
the neutrophils release various enzymes
that kill and digest the pathogen they
are normally found in the bloodstream
and are short-lived and highly mobile as
they can enter paths of tissue where
other cells or molecules cannot
neutrophils are usually the first cells
to respond to any infection or
inflammation this is due to their
heightened ability to sense what's going
around the body by detecting special
chemical signals released by pathogens
and by our own body cells that tell them
what's going around in the body if you
look at a neutrophil it has some
characteristic features the first thing
you would notice is the multi lobe
nucleus of the cell this is a normal
appearance of the nucleus and this is a
reason why neutrophils are also known as
polymorphonuclear leukocytes
polymorphonuclear meaning the nucleus of
the cell has multiple morphologies
meaning some neutrophils have two lobes
in their nucleus some three or four or
five so there are multiple morphologies
the nucleus of these neutrophils can
have so they are also known as the
polymorphonuclear leukocytes another
characteristic feature you would notice
in the structure of these cells is the
presence of large number of channels in
the cytoplasm on an average about 200 to
250 granules are present in each
neutrophil and these granules contain
many different types of enzymes
chemicals and cytokines that have
numerous functions in our immune system
the neutrophils release enzymes like
milo peroxidase defensins serine
proteases and various cytokines that
have numerous functions in our immune
system they're also released several
other chemicals like alkaline
phosphatase NADPH oxidase
like zoos I'm that help in eliminating
these pathogens like I told you they are
phagocytic cells that detect and eat a
pathogens like bacteria upon ingesting
the bacteria the bacteria is contained
in this bubble like structure known as
the fake ozone this phagosome gets fused
with lysosome the granule of the cell
which contains the lysosome in them
which is a type of enzyme the
combination leads to formation of a
Faygo lysosome very cellular enzymes
kill the bacteria and digest it the next
type of vibra cells we have are known as
the EU NFL's USANA Phil's also have a
similar-looking nucleus two neutrophils
but it usually has only two lobes
hence named as a goggle shaped nucleus
they also contain numerous cellular
granules that contain different types of
chemicals and enzymes
in normal individuals you know Phil's
make up about one to three percent of
the white blood cells and are
responsible for combating multicellular
parasites and certain bacterial
infections there are also a sauna fills
that play a vital role in fighting
infections when unchecked you know
Phil's are responsible for tissue damage
and inflammation in many diseases
including asthma
another type of WBC of the innate immune
system is the base of film
basophils are the least common of the w
pcs representing about 0.5 to 1% of the
circulating white blood cells
basophils have a very important role in
fighting the parasitic infections of the
body in addition to fighting parasitic
infections basophils play our role in
preventing blood clotting as basophils
contain heparin
they are also implicated in various
allergic reactions
marcelles are a type of
immune cells that reside in the
connective tissue and in the mucous
membranes like the lining of our
respiratory and gastrointestinal system
mast cells are associated with wound
healing and defense against pathogens
but are often associated with allergy
and anaphylaxis which has serious
allergic reactions that lead cause death
marcelles also have numerous granules in
them that contained abundant quantities
of histamine and heparin histamine
dilates blood vessels which produces the
characteristic signs of inflammation and
recruits neutrophils and macrophages
they also help to link the innate and
adaptive immunity to fight against
pathogens the next two important cells
that we have in the innate immune system
are the monocytes and the macrophages
macrophages from the Greek word meaning
large eaters are large phagocytic
leukocytes which are able to move
outside of the vascular system by
migrating across the walls of blood
vessels and entering the areas between
the cells in pursuit of invading
pathogens similar types of cells when
present circulating in the blood are
known as the monocytes we call
neutrophils eosinophils and basophils as
polymorphonuclear cells as a name
indicated their nucleus contained
multiple lobes if you look at the word
monocyte this literally means cell with
one local nuclear and as you can see the
nucleus of monocyte in macrophage is
round to oval with only one lobe the
binding of bacterial molecules to the
receptors on the surface of a macrophage
triggers it to engulf and destroy the
bacteria through the generation of
reactive oxygen species pathogens also
stimulate the macrophage to produce
chemokines which are special chemicals
that attract other immune cells to the
site of infection
another type of innate immune cell that
we have in our body is the tender it
Excel the word dendrite means branches
and these are known as dendritic cells
because they have branch like
projections from these cells dendritic
cells are present in those tissues that
are in contact with the external
environment such as the skin
and inner lining of nose lungs stomach
and intestines the dendritic cells are a
type of antigen presenting cells antigen
presenting cells detect the pathogens
and they take the antigens that are
present on the surface of these
pathogens two lymphocytes lymphocytes
are cells of adaptive immunity that we
will discuss in a bit the dendritic
cells present these antigens to the
lymphocytes and this leads to attack on
the pathogen by these lymphocytes and
the antibodies they produce so they are
known as the antigen presenting cells as
they present the antigen to the
lymphocytes dendritic cells are also
known as the Langerhans cells after the
scientists who discovered them type 1
interferons secreted mainly by dendritic
cells play a central role in the body's
defense against viruses the last cell
type that we will discuss in the cells
of the innate immunity are the natural
killer cells or the NK cells NK cells
are the component of the innate immune
system that does not directly attack the
invading microbes rather NK cells
destroy our own cells that have become
defective such as tumor cells or virus
infected cells
so these are various types of cells that
are present in our innate immune system
apart from the physical and chemical
barriers and various types of cells the
innate immune system also has a special
type of defense mechanism known as the
complement system
the compliment system is a set of about
20 proteins and it is known as the
compliment system as it complements the
action of the antibodies and other cells
in destroying the pathogens meaning the
complement system helps the antibodies
and other immune cells to destroy the
invading microbes many species have
complement systems including the non
mammals like plants fishes and some
invertebrates too
the basic mechanism of action of the
complement system is as follows whenever
any pathogen enters a body it gets
recognized by antibodies present in our
blood the binding of antibody to the
pathogen is the most important factor
for the activation of complement system
after it is activated a cascade of
different enzymes acts on the surface of
the microbe to kill it after it is
activated a cascade of different enzymes
acts on the surface of the microbe to
kill it the complement system has many
different mechanisms of action but if
you want to learn about the complement
system in more detail make sure to watch
the video on the topic of complement
system on our channel links are in the
description below so this was about the
innate immune system the type of
immunity that is present since birth
it is nonspecific and comparatively
weaker as compared to our third line of
defense that is the adaptive immunity
the adaptive immune system also known as
the acquired immune system or more
rarely the specific immune system is
composed of highly specialized systemic
cells and processes that eliminate the
pathogens or prevent their growth
adaptive immunity is not present since
birth and it is created in response to
exposure to a foreign substance that is
why the name adaptive immunity as it
adapts accordingly to the type of
threats that we are exposed to
when a pathogen invades our first and
second line of defense it is met by the
adaptive immunity which mainly consists
of lymphocytes and the antibodies they
produce and when a particular pathogen
enters our body for the first time the
response of the adaptive immunity is
minimal as it doesn't recognize this
pathogen yet it remembers his exposure
to the pathogen and stores an
immunological memory of this encounter
so if you draw the first response of the
adaptive immune system on a graph it
would look something like this upon
subsequent exposure to the same pathogen
there is an amplified response of the
adaptive immune system sending multiple
types of lymphocytes and antibodies that
are specific for that pathogen only this
helps in successfully eliminating the
pathogen the system is highly adaptable
because once encountered the
immunological memory of that pathogen
remains in our system forever and upon
subsequent invasion by the same pathogen
a full mounted defense system is already
present in our body
the cells of the acquired immune system
are the T lymphocytes and the B
lymphocytes lymphocytes are a subset of
leukocytes meaning they are also types
of white blood cells B cells and T cells
are the major types of lymphocytes the
human body has about two trillion
lymphocytes constituting 20 to 40% of
the WBC's their total mass is about the
same as a brain or a liver the
peripheral blood contains 2% circulating
lymphocytes the rest of them move within
the tissue spaces and the lymphatic
system the adaptive immune system is
divided into two main types the humoral
immunity which is due to the B
lymphocytes and the cellular immunity
which is due to the t lymphocytes the T
lymphocytes are again divided into two
major types the helper T cells and the
cytotoxic or the killer T cells the
cytotoxic or the cd8 T cells have a
major role in killing the pathogens by
directly interacting with invading
microbes whereas the helper T cells or
the cd4 T cells have a indirect but a
very important role in our immune system
the helper T cells are responsible for
the proper functioning of the rest of
the immune cells including their close
cousins the cd8 cells they secrete large
number of growth factors and their
cytokines that are essential for
maturation of other types of immune
cells one of the most deadliest diseases
of our century AIDS or acquired
immunodeficiency syndrome acts by
killing our cd4 or the T helper cells
only the number decreases so much that
it cripples our whole immune system and
our body gets overwhelmed by a lot of
infections that do not usually occur in
normal healthy person the other major
type of lymphocyte in our blood are the
B lymphocytes which are responsible for
the humoral immunity
the b-lymphocytes produce a special type
of protein known as the antibody which
looks something like this as you can see
it is a y-shaped structure in which the
terminal end of the protein is specially
designed to recognize and capture
antigens that are present on the surface
of bacteria and other pathogens this of
course happens after the B lymphocytes
have had their first contact with the
pathogen earlier which led to an
immunological memory stored inside these
cells upon subsequent encounter with the
same pathogen by the B lymphocytes the
cells produce a large number of antigen
specific antibodies that recognize and
capture the invading pathogen now the
antibodies do not destroy these invading
pathogens by themselves but activate a
number of different mechanisms of our
immune system including the complement
system and the various types of Fable it
excels like neutrophils one of the very
important function of these antibodies
is known as the opsonization this in
simple words just means sugarcoating a
pill to make it more tasty now what
these antibodies do is that when they
recognize a particular pathogen they
attach to it and they completely coat it
with lots of antibodies this is known as
opsonization the coated cell acts like a
signal to other immune cells like the
neutrophils which come and digest the
coated cell therefore the antibodies
mark the pathogens so they can be
destroyed by other immune cells now
there are five different types of
antibodies with different roles if you
want to learn more about the structure
of antibody and its function and the
complement system make sure to watch
these videos on our channel links are in
the description below
the last section of our basis of immune
system will be the differences between
the innate and adaptive immunity when we
look at how each type of immunity
develops the innate immunity is
something that is present since our
birth while the adaptive immune system
is a type of immunity that develops
after we are born talking about
specificity the innate immunity is
nonspecific whereas the adaptive
immunity is very specific and I hope you
are clear with the meaning of the word
specificity here innate immunity is
nonspecific as it doesn't have any
specialized defense systems for
different types of pathogens rather it
uses a common defense system to kill all
the types of pathogens and a single
immune defense mechanism of the innate
immunity is able to defend against a
wide variety of pathogens this is in
contrast to the specific immune system
that has special types of antibodies and
cells that are specific and act only on
the pathogens they recognize when we
look at the time that each system takes
to respond to an infection the innate
immune system has a very rapid response
to any infection since this type of
immunity is already present in our body
while the adaptive immune system is slow
to respond as it needs the first
exposure to develop a memory of the
pathogen if we look at the potency of
each system the innate immune system is
less potent as compared to the adaptive
immunity which just means that the
adaptive immune system has more power to
kill pathogens since of course it has
cells and antibodies that are made
specifically for that pathogen one
important difference between the innate
and the adaptive immune system is that
the innate type of immunity is generally
inherited from parents and passed off to
the offsprings while the adaptive
immunity is not passed from the parents
to the offspring hence it cannot be
inherited if we look at the evolutionary
basis the innate immunity is older and
is found in both vertebrates and
invertebrates while the adaptive immune
system has been developed recently and
is found only in vertebrates the various
components of the innate immune system
of physical and chemical barriers
phagocytic leukocytes dendritic cells
and natural killer cells while the
adaptive immune system is composed of T
cells B cells and the antibodies they
produce so this was a basic overview
about the human immune system as I told
you previously you can get the lecture
handouts from this video and the
flashcards as well
by joining our channel click the join
button below you can also support our
channel by joining our community at
patreon.com all links are in the
description below thank you so much for
watching this video see you in the next
one